ah yes but what's crazy about [ __ ]
Washington DC is here's the thing you
need an update Washington DC okay you
need an update all right do you know why
because
in like the year
1850 there weren't that many people
uh when was the car made like 19
something or before that
it's like nineteen thousand
1900s then like eight you know I know I
read a book about Henry Ford when I was
in [ __ ] school dude
and um
there's a picture book and so and he
like
in in 1850
it was fine to have like everything's so
close to each other like the Washington
Monument like the [ __ ] uh the Lincoln
Memorial
man I was thinking when I see that why
when I think of the Washington Monument
I always think of uh what's his name
Talib Kweli saying and my cash looked
more like Dickson Washington monuments
so bad
um and our cash look more like dicks
than watching The Monuments so bad and
so um and real Hip Hop Heads would be
like but that's real hip hop you know I
mean
that's real hip-hop
a cat should look like dicks more than
the Washington one if you want to know
if hip-hop lyrics are actually really
good same in a radio announcer voice
you know what I mean like when you hear
Yoshi it's your birthday oh shorty you
know we don't give a [ __ ] it's your
birthday like you're like [ __ ] yeah dude
in Vegas that's nice
but when you're when you say it like go
shorty it's your birthday and you know
we don't give a [ __ ] because it's not
your birthday then you realize okay it's
actually bad
our cash stack more like dicks
than the Washington Monument
um tonight at 11 and so
anyway
um it was fine in 1850 okay
but hey it's 2022. not only are there
[ __ ] bicycles not only are there cars
but there's Ubers someone will just
drive you four blocks away
to where the president lives
should be illegal
dude you can just
walk up to where the leader of the Free
World
resides
hey that's got to change because of
dirty bombs and crazy people
I want my president living way out there
just like in a side of a [ __ ] mouth I
want him safety I don't give a [ __ ] who
it is Trump
the lizard Biden it doesn't matter
I don't care who it is
you know whether it's Trump or [ __ ]
Joe Biden and if he's just fresh from
the ocean and he [ __ ] shed his scales
and he came back into this White House I
want the White House in the side of a
[ __ ] mountain in the middle of some
place where there's other mountains that
look just like it and we can't tell
which mountain it's in dude it's so
insane that in this day and age
that you can just hey just walk right up
you could be staying at a W Hotel and
just walk three blocks
and yell for the president through his
wind
press
Biden
I'm in room 315 at the at the W Hotel if
you want to come in I'm getting [ __ ]
sliders
Biden trying to sleep God damn it
because this is a lizard
um but yeah dude that's got to change
this is why I say tradition ruins
everything because the president lives
there still because he lived there for
since 17 or whatever the [ __ ] it was you
know I'm bad with dates
but
you need to update that [ __ ] with the
time tradition ruins everything Wars and
every but even more than religion
tradition religion is tradition any
tradition is [ __ ] up right my dad used
to want to read the [ __ ] what was the
train Christmas book what's that called
Polar Express every Christmas day you
wanted to read it and that was cool when
I was 6 and 11
but dude he we had to stop him like five
years I'm 42. five years ago I'm like
Dad I just you know it's like I don't I
it's fine I get it he's just like put
the magic of Christmas and I'm like I'm
37.
that's fine can you can we just not read
it and he's like but it's tradition then
you get me all pent up and then before
you know what I don't want to come over
for Christmas that's a very micro to the
world's macro but I'm saying that kind
of [ __ ] is the micro and the macro is
walking up to the [ __ ] White House
and rocket launcher in the new [ __ ]
device the VP
um
yeah I mean it's crazy you could just
pop in an Uber and be like the White
House
like I get it America but also
chilly
[Music]
crazy crazy congratulations
[Music]